but first we're following breaking news
about a deadly shooting at the home of a
federal
judge a manhunt is underway after a
gunman opened fire on the family of
judge esther salas
in new jersey her son was killed and her
husband
wounded she was unharmed errol barnett
is at the scene errol we're hearing the
fbi
is involved that's right anthony good
morning the fbi now leading this
investigation coordinating with u.s
marshals
and state and local police and what they
tell cbs news is that the suspect was
dressed
as a delivery driver when he approached
the house you see behind me on sunday
that's when the judge's husband that's
defense attorney mark anderl
answered the door and was shot the
gunman also
shot and killed the couple's
twenty-year-old son daniel
sources say the judge was in the home's
basement at the time of the shooting
and was unharmed and has been rushed to
the hospital and is believed to be in
stable condition
but the big question revolves around the
motive for the shooting it is unknown
and it's also unclear who the actual
target was considering the judge's
husband himself as a defense attorney
now salas has presided over a few
high-profile cases in recent years
ranging from
drug and gang violence cases including
one involving the [ __ ] street gang
and she's also presiding over a lawsuit
filed by investors against deutsche bank
for allegedly failing to monitor
questionable transactions by convicted
sex offender jeffrey epstein
now we have to be crystal clear right
now there is no
link between those trials
and court proceedings and this shooting
on sunday and gail that is why the fbi
is pleading for anyone with information
to reach out to the agency
errol thank you that's always absolutely
terrifying thank you very much